Stephanie is in Orange County
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
Stephanie thank you Dave and thank you
for your time in picking Nicole
summarize my household is my husband and
I our annual anytime is ninety one
thousand and our debt is thirty thousand
we've been following your plan for
several months now and we were able to
pay down three thousand dollars in debt
everything was going great until my car
started shutting off on me while I'm
driving it
we paid my husband's car off last month
mine I could probably sell it for the
salary right Oh on it or be a little
upside down on it so I left it with my
mechanic for a total of three weeks he's
been driving it around with the code
reader attached to it and it just will
not shut off on him for him to get a
code the car does not give a code I
guess the issue is too short for it to
be imprinted into the memory of the
computer of the car so I just recently
found out that I am pregnant sorry oh
it's wonderful
I know pacing my car and I don't know
what to do what's a car just solid well
but I would have to finance another one
well your this one's financed seven
thousand eleven thousand sure sure you
can find a good car for seven thousand
lots of good cars for seven thousand
let's get you an old Honda Accord that's
very unusual that they go bad it gets
you an old Camry then I don't care but
their realize there's lots of reliable
seven thousand dollar cars okay so
you're not against me financing it for
the same amount just not going over well
you're not going further in debt okay if
you go less than that or equal all
you're doing is trading places and
you're getting rid of your freaked out
while you're pregnant because you're
having a pregnant freak out where your
car's shutting off for no apparent
reason there
a ghost in the machine right yeah that
dump the stupid thing it's a car okay
okay thank you Donna
appreciate your call and congratulations
on the baby folks that's a great call
right there to illustrate sweet lady
baby on the way good stuff okay but how
many times I have I have a drama queen
that lives inside of me
you have one that lives inside of you
that goes into freakout mode and you
look back later and you go
you're just a wuss what are you freaking
out about but at the moment it feels
like the world's coming to an inn and
every time i emotionally paint myself in
a corner and I have the ability to do it
today not as much now that I'm older and
uglier and all that but especially when
I was younger I could I can really get
into some drama inside between my ears
and convince myself that crap was going
on that really wasn't going on or the
things were about like 10x worse than
they really were and as soon as I get
desperate right after that I get stupid
and right after I get stupid I get broke
and when you get desperate and you paint
yourself in the corner I've done it and
you know she's got a little pregnancy
freakout mode going there that's okay
that just means you're human than mean
you're bad person I'm not picking on you
I'm just saying we all have this
capacity to blow things up inside of our
mind to a level that they're not really
and then we just crash around and do
damage to our finances that's pretty
severe that lady could have been that
exact same situation and call me up six
months from now and go well about a
$30,000 car and those people would call
me for 30 years on this show I was
forced to buy a car you were forced to
do squat you just gotten stupid
mode right after you got in a desperate
mode right after you got in drama mode
and then we all can do that I have done
it I've done it and you know you get in
a position you're you don't have a car
and so you're like feel forced to do
something so here's the thing listen to
this one I had a guy the other day I was
talking to and he was but you know he he
was between cars he sold his car he
didn't have a car and so he was like
panicking it was a personal conversation
of one here on the air and he was
getting ready to go buy a $30,000 car on
that I'm so confused
do you not know that you can go down a
dollar to run a car in rent you a car
for like 100 bucks go into a car instead
of making a $30,000 Asian once you make
$100 decision and take the pressure off
the situation I have that around for a
week getting spend a little bit of money
but it's not it's not something you'd
want do for the rest of your life and
it's not a good long-term decision but
you know app uber just call uber look
left and come get you
calm your butt down
do not go buy a $30,000 car because
you're in freakout mode and that's what
I'm telling this guy and it was like you
know I never thought I could just you
know you can Oberer for like the rest of
your life for 30 grand you know not that
you want to or not that you have to not
that that's a good idea I'm not saying
it is but in an amazing how a little bit
of expenditure to take the pressure off
takes us out of desperation mode versus
and then we don't do this big
expenditure on drama based impulse and
you know people run buy a house it's
like they think they're gonna be
homeless freak just go around apartment
man went wrong you don't have to go ya
have to spend $500,000 now you don't you
can
but this idea that somehow you were
forced to do that and we do this inside
of our heads and she wasn't that bad she
was pretty good our last call her there
she had her shoes she called me she's
trying to hold on she's trying to think
through it and but man I do that and you
do it too and here's the thing you can
do smart stuff for 10 years and and
screw up almost everything you did with
a couple of bad decisions by not taking
by not thinking things through and
feeling when you go into fear mode and
you're doing financial stuff out of fear
you are really getting ready to mess up
most of the time so there you go
something to think about calm your butt
down that's that's what I have to say to
myself and I'll go ahead and say it to
you guys too